doesn't understand where I come from I
don't think I think you guys just think
that that I'm kind of boxed into this
Western box no I don't I'm really not
it's very different than most women I
think this is a very unique do you want
to live in two houses with your husband
in the future do you want to get married
and have two separate houses no okay I
have an extra house just in case it has
happened for myself not like living okay
like you won't have Separate Lives you
know I want to have the same life with
my husband but I also would like a house
for myself close by so if I had an
argument never mind I guess it's not
like a thing I want to live with my
husband just in case he kicks me out
just you know like a backup plan how
much is that house in the UK 500k so
okay you do so you're planning to get a
million pounds
it's something that I would love to have
like a backup plan because anything can
happen I agree